hello freak [ __ ] hey let me ask you
this we left him to Bill Maher I've
never been a bill mark now what do you
think of this whole recent controversy
of him just casually dropping a time
bomb
yeah yeah he was trying to make a joke
exactly right yeah I mean didn't work
but he's trying to be naughty yeah
that's all but they're making it seem
like it's something more there you have
its words or like you said this is like
yes said said not did did is worse but
it's only not hire black people so
that's a major issue he's never hired a
black person but I don't think I've
heard that so it's like his actions
aren't we were talking about before the
podcast this thing where the were
talking about the Clintons and Arkansas
yeah in the governor's mansion yeah what
show was that which shows it did you see
Jamie I read it I didn't see it on the
show oh you read it was getting passed
around the internet yesterday mmm how
thoughtful
it's got to be Russian disinformation it
could be who knows but apparently but
when Bill Maher when they go like
troubling from Bill I mean I get even
the Republican senator they was there
with it was like was like I'm a little
uncomfortable is but sure be
uncomfortable and if a guy watching a
guy who uses words that make me
uncomfortable time I'll stop watching I
guess you know Twitter erupts over news
that Hillary Clinton used black prison
labor while first lady of Arkansas
Newsweek calm but does it have to do
with JFK JFK push the Democrats to
Democrat rival connecting to twist them
to the right and having totally
different music huh
okay when we moved in I was told that
using prison labor at the governor's
mansion was a long-standing tradition
which kept down cost Clinton rights she
has that most of the workers were
convicted murderers and she became
friendly with and quotes a few of them
african-american men in their 30s who
had already served 12 to 18 years their
sentences who despite their alleged
friendships with these men Clinton tells
her readers we enforced rules strictly
and sent back to prison any inmate who
broke a rule despite having no
psychological qualification she later
asserts that these men did not have
inferior IQs or an ability to apply
moral reasoning but instead they may
have been emotional the literate
emotional illiterate that's what she
said the helices despite having no
psychological qualifications ya later
served despite having no ability to say
those to touch him it's kind of weird
though that slave labor yeah that is
exactly what that is
I mean without it's just tradition it's
like yeah but that doesn't mean should
do it let's be honest like how much are
they getting paid zero what [ __ ] one
pack of cigarettes a week yeah what do
they get they do not pay inmates at all
oh Jesus Christ
Clinton makes no mention of whether or
not these men received any money for
working for her and her husband at 2016
article for Mother Jones notes that when
it came to prison when it comes to
prison labor some state states include
Texas Arkansas and Georgia do not pay
inmates at all holy [ __ ]
on Twitter Jing wrote that Hillary
Clinton was a direct participant in what
Sam su sway Sam Swain it's at Sam's Way
on Twitter I guess correctly described
as modern slavery a hundred percent well
dude that's a hundred percent slavery if
you don't pay someone you make them work
because they did a crime that's a crazy
thing like it was a boat but you're
making them work that's what's crazy
about it it's like it's not just that
you your your freedoms taken away and
they lock you in a box but they also
make you work
saying your lives aren't worth anything
we can make it do it everyone
you